he's not even going to try to give me
time updates
um that's a joke don't worry so um I'm
gonna move this down a bit
yeah okay
um good so
this talk is about loss decompression
and I'm hoping to speak to both
um what uh machine learning can provide
to information theory in terms of new
schemes and new architectures and so on
and also perhaps what information Theory
can provide machine learning in terms of
performance bounds and crisp optimality
results and and so on so this is Joint
work with Sarah bandani who's a PhD
student at Cornell who's graduating next
month and Johannes ballet who's uh
Google research
all right so let me Begin by just
describing the classical story about
loss decompression from information
Theory so this is sort of a folklore
result it's probably familiar to most
people here but let me go through it
kind of quickly for good measure so
um if you open up a textbook
and information Theory and read up on
how to compress a source subject to a
mean squared error Distortion constraint
it'll say they do the following
so you take okay assuming your source is
like a 1D time series okay so you take
your Source you divide it into
um chunks of size J so blocks of size J
and then you apply a linear decorating
transform to it so the left transform or
some you know fast uh kind of
approximation thereof you get to
transform coefficients and then you
quantize these so ecdq stands for
entropy entropy constrained dither
quantization so at a high level you just
think about taking each transform
coefficient and then quantizing it
according to a uniform quantizer you get
these uh quantized coefficients these
are discrete random variables now you
pump it all through your favorite you
know Universal losses compression
algorithm and those are your bits and
that's the compressed representation
and then the decoder side you just kind
of undo this as best you can so
um get the reconstructed transform
coefficient so the quantized transform
coefficients and then invert the
transform
into our
so this has an optimality result behind
it this kind of overall architecture so
it's within a quarter bit of optimal if
the source is stationary and gaussian
which is kind of a big if but um but at
least you know it has it has that result
it's also an asymptotic result so low
Distortion okay so so high rate
stationary gaussian mean squared error
this architectures provably near optimal
within a quarter bit
and it forms the the framework within
which all the kind of standard
um uh compression standards that we know
and love for music and video or forms so
JPEG and MP3 and AAC and bpc and
everything they're all you know formed
from this um from this basic
architecture with you know tweaks to uh
to make it work all the better
okay so
um this was sort of like the state of
the art from maybe about you know the
mid 70s when kind of the final pieces
were put in place in this story until
you know about 2015 and then like many
other areas uh deep neural networks just
kind of blew this area wide open so um
here's one just one performance plot
this one's a bit dated it's from a
number of years ago but it gives you you
know a sense of what's going on so these
are just simple rate Distortion curves
SNR versus bits this is for the Kodak
data set so there's jpeg jpeg 2000 those
represent like the culmination you know
of like Decades of optimization of this
architecture and so here's their curves
the dark you know the black and black
hashed and in comparison here are two
neural network based compressors for the
Kodak data set
um that are already handily beating it
um and again the jpeg are like
thoroughly optimized this is like the
first and second cut if you will of the
you know the neural network approach
and it's already doing certainly better
so what's the difference so
um what are neural networks bringing to
the table so well first of all there are
various approaches for using deep neural
networks for velocity compression of
images and music and so on I'm going to
focus on one particular approach that
sometimes called non-linear transform
coding
um that approach adheres quite closely
to the classical architecture on some
level we just replaced the linear
transform with a nonlinear transform
okay so the the linear klt the DCT gets
replaced with a neural network
um and of course it's trained okay so
the neural the the linear transform was
formed from you know mathematically from
some model
um these transforms are now trained you
know kind of end to end
but you know at a high level it's like
you know what was a linear transform is
now non-linear and
um and that's the tweak that's the
change
all right and for images the speeds
linear transforms as we saw in a
previous uh slide even under mean
squared error okay so the real power of
this method is that you don't have to
use mean squared error right like any
Distortion measure you can differentiate
okay you can you can optimize Force you
can use metrics that you know capture
human perceived Distortion much better
than the mean squared error does but
even on the home turf of the classical
method okay this is still beating the
classical method the classical
architecture
okay so what can we take away from The
Story So Far
um evidently images are not stationary
gaussian processes like this is not a
big surprise to people but this like
seals it right because if they were then
like non-linear methods should really
buy us nothing per the theorem and
they're buying us something so you know
that's the end of that
um and you know as such like the theory
that's based on that assumption is also
kind of out the window right I mean the
classical Theory says you shouldn't need
non-linear methods and yet we do so it's
like that classical theory is not you
know evidently so useful anymore
it's a plus it's trained for a data set
however large it is and these are
generalized transforms for any data
of course you have to tune the Huffman
coding tables for appropriately but I
don't think it's a fair comparison sir
what are you comparing like just as you
compared you said
I mean they're not yeah that's why we
improved with an ends yes
sure yes they are I mean jpeg does have
a um a wider region of robustness I
think than the general networks that's
true but you know it's not like it only
works for like cases or something
foreign
Ty like I said you can learn the
covariance structure from data
yeah so there are there are two
distinctions right there's the training
and there's a non-linearity yeah and I
agree I'm sweeping the training part
Under The Rock and of course I'm not
minority but yeah
right but he says you don't need to know
the model is the universal rate
Distortion coding up to a quarter a
quarter bit whereas the transform part
also takes takes that but combines it
with some Source modeling yeah so I
think what he's saying is that the
transform needs to be nonlinear
that's the point sorry I'll let you take
it yes
all right so you know I would posit that
the classical Theory at least as I put
up there is uh not so useful moving
forward and that you know it indicates
that the denominator transforms are not
useful and evidently they are so
um we'd like to develop a new Theory to
kind of replace the old
um one that can do all the things we
want of a theory so explain why things
that work well in practice work well
um in practice quantify their Gap from
optimality and maybe show how they can
be improved
visual value of the information provides
us you know we'd like to we like to
obtain that and I do not have a you know
a brand new Theory a rate Distortion to
to provide you here I have two kind of
toy models these are both Source models
um that oh they're simple do actually
speak to all three of these points as
we'll see
so there's two of them we call them the
sawbridge and the ramp and
um they they do speak to all three and I
think moreover they
um they're they're very they're toy
models they're stylized but they do
capture certain properties of images so
you know they both have homogeneous
regions separated by an Abrupt Edge and
the edge is kind of randomly placed and
they also capture this idea of like low
dimensional structure and high
dimensional space the so-called manifold
hypothesis for
um for images okay so I'm going to talk
about each of them I'll do the sawbridge
and then and then the ramp
all right let's do the star Bridge first
so it's a continuous time random process
over zero one quite simple
so which is X of T equals t with a
random unit drop
with a unit drop at a random time a
uniform distributed time over zero one
okay so a typical realization will look
at this okay so which is X of T equals t
um except that there's a unit drop at a
random time you
the process okay so it's like an image
right that's like a Wendy image right
you have these like two textures and
then there's a edge between them right
okay so
um
uh we did not invent this process okay
we learned about it from this very nice
um uh survey paper by Donahoe at all
um they call it the ramp
um we call it the sawbridge both because
we think it's a more descriptive name
for this process it's a bridge right it
starts and finishes at the same time and
also we want to use the word ramp for
another process that comes later in the
talk so so we're going to change the
name they credit
um meyer92
um I can tell you I pulled up the minor
92 paper myself I read it start to
finish I cannot find any reference to a
process that resembles this at all so
I'm not probably my deserves credit but
maybe not the paper they um they cite in
any event it's not our creation
but it's a great example to to study
um in part because like you want to talk
about low dimensional structure in high
dimensional space like this has the
maximum possible discrepancy between the
two okay it's a one-dimensional process
it's completely described by the U okay
and yet uh the energy is spread over
infinitely many dimensions okay any
five-dimensional Subspace is not going
to capture all the energy of the process
okay so like infinite dimensional space
with like a one-dimensional spline in it
and that's the process
okay so let's talk about compression so
how well can we compress this process so
here's the formulation we'll use so an
encoder is a map from function space to
some discrete set
and we're going to look at the trade-off
between the entropy and the mean squared
error so an encoder is just a map from
the function space to a discrete set
like I said and we want to minimize the
entropy of the output of the encoder
subject to a mean squared error
constraint it's not the only way to
formulating of course this is one shot
so compare with the rate Distortion
function where you get like you know
many realizations of the gaussian source
here you get one Strawbridge realization
you can press that that's it there are
many copies of this thing the sawbridge
is your image okay it doesn't represent
like one pixel it's like the whole the
whole image
um entry of course approximates the
expected chord length
and
um this is actually what the a n
compressors that we've been looking at
are optimized for they try to minimize
the entropy discrete entropy at the
output of the encoder subject to saving
squared error Distortion constraint so
if we want to you know compare these
curves that you get from this uh this
definition against you know actual plots
and neural networks make sense to you
know look at what they're trying to
optimize which is which is this okay
so this process is simple enough you can
actually compute
h of Delta exactly uh it's implicit but
it is exact so the the power in the
process is a sixth so mean squared error
above that the rate required is zero
anything less than that you can compute
it you know implicitly in terms of these
these formulas
um at a very high level you basically
want to like quantize you can I go back
like the process is completely described
by the location of the drop right so
just intuitively like the encoder should
just like identify where U is quantize
that tell the D card location of you
within synchronization error and then
you know the the decoder just creates an
mmsc estimate of the of the whole
function given that information so so
the proof here just amounts of showing
that like give me any encoder I can
dominate it by one with that quantizes
you using contiguous cells you then have
to optimize the cell sizes this is a
non-convex optimization problem
um this turns out to be kind of
non-trivial but it's actually equivalent
to
um equanization problem solved in a
different context in in this paper and
so this would give you this
characterization all right so
um this is a bit messy it's useful to
look at asymptotics so as the ray goes
to infinity or equivalently the
Distortion goes to zero
um the rate blows up as uh one over the
so log one over the Distortion
um which may be a touch surprising you
might expect a half here because it's
like a one parameter process
um but there's actually not a half there
that's
maybe a topic for another talk why that
happens uh anyway log one over Delta is
the main takeaway
um you can look at how well the
classical architecture compresses this
and the answer is very poorly
okay so first you work out the klt for
this process
this process has the same
autocorrelation and hence the same klt
as the Brownian Bridge so
um you know if you can open up more
textbooks and kind of write down the
orthogonal basis and stuff
um the real contribution of our theorem
here just to point out that like the
coefficients in the klt can be expressed
quite simply in terms of that U variable
that you know describes the process
which is useful because now we can you
know talk about the entropy of just like
quantized versions of Y and then you
know
um plot that and compare that against
optimality okay so if you consider the
entropy of
um like the classical architecture so
you know klt coefficiency water fill you
entropy code them
you get an entropy for a given
distortion
as the destruction goes to zero that
entry blows up as one over Delta
so it is exponentially sub-optimal right
answers log one over Delta this is one
over Delta without the log
okay
um essentially because it can't it's a
linear transform it can't extract the U
okay so it has to like project into all
these different dimensions and then like
you know try to describe all of these
like uncorrelated random variables that
are of course highly dependent with each
other there's one U that controls them
all right so you don't really need all
these all these bits
um yeah the entry blows up is constant
divided by Delta we can describe the
consonants a big mess it's like a
convolution and should be of a
convolution of arc sine density and so
on but
you can compute it numerically 0.3
Okay so
how will the neural networks do
so it's not hard by the way to write
down by hand a shallow neural network
that compresses this thing optimally
okay so now the question is not like is
there a neural network that compresses
this thing well the question is can like
stochastic training find it okay and if
you take like off-the-shelf neural
network compressors for images and just
train them on this instead like you know
how well do they do
so we took the off the shelf uh
state-of-the-art neural network
compressor for images
um and trained it on a bunch of
sawbridge realizations and you know all
the details are here you got to quantize
the or discretize the process sample the
process in time of course has to work
with a vector not a continuous time
process
um these are all the details I won't
spend too much time on these
[Music]
um
maybe I'll just point out that like
there is a um for people who aren't
familiar with this particular
application of neural networks there's a
complication here in that like to to do
lossy compression you got to quantize to
get bits uh quantizers like a pure
quantizer has a zero derivative almost
everywhere right so if you have like a
straight quantizer in the middle here
you cannot back propagate through this
and get anything useful out of it so you
need some kind of work around for that
there's always work around that people
have used you can do dither
so you minimize like some proxy for the
rate plus Lambda times the Distortion
with like you know another variable that
kind of softens the edge of the
quantizer
um the state of the art approach uh is
actually to start with that and then
over the course of the training like
anneal to
um a hard quantization to kind of move
from this to this over the course of
training you got to get the kind of the
quenching schedule right and stuff
um but anyway this is this is Augustine
base approach which um which works best
Okay so
numerical results for the sawbridge so
this is the optimal curve just from the
theorem so SNR versus versus rate
um log one over Delta so it's linear on
a semi-log scale and we train the neural
network on this just giving it
um you know sawbridge realizations to
train on and then plotted its
performance and it is spot on
okay it's not order optimal or like
within a constant I mean it's just
right on the curve so it Nails it
um we also Force the neural network to
use a klt
okay so we kind of lock the transforms
to be a klt but we allow it to do like
water filling gain optimization and we
compute the performance experimentally
like we did for for here and you see
it's exponentially sub-optimal you can
plot a theory curve here too and it's
more or less the same we don't show the
theory curve
um if you take the neural network and
remove the
um the non-linear activations but allow
it to optimize the transform so find the
best linear transform that does quite a
bit better
actually it was still quite sub-optimal
so klt is not the best transform
with this example
you can also lock the neural network to
use you know whatever you want like a
VCT or a certain wavelet or whatever and
like none of those really seem to buy
you anything they're just doing the
given to the klt performance back which
is interesting because the Donahoe at
all paper I mentioned earlier so they
they introduce the I shouldn't say they
introduce because I guess the process
goes back to Meyer but
um they talk about the um The Sovereign
process as a vehicle for understanding
why wavelets
work so well as the correlating
transform so the paper's written in the
90s when wavelets were you know the
emerging technology and
um
yeah we find actually that wavelets
don't really help much at all but
non-linear approaches just blow
everything else out of the water
okay so that's the starbridge part so
the star Bridge simple as it is can
explain the success of
non-linear transforms
let's quantify their Gap from optimality
zero given that it's zero they don't
speak to how to improved the the network
because there's nothing to improve but
that takes us to the ramp
so let's move on to the second example
so just a tweak to the process okay very
similar process but not exactly the same
so this process is X of T equals T minus
half with a random cyclic shift to it
okay so just you know X of T equals T
minus a half and then just apply a
random cyclic shift to the whole thing
so you know it's a typical realization
again a 1D manifold in function space
this one's a circle however
okay and that like you realizations that
are close to one and utilizations that
are close to zero give you a function
realization is very close to each other
okay so the Sovereign
this is really like a circle
in function space and we'll see that's
significant
impression purposes okay so we can run
through the whole program
um you can characterize the optimal
compressor for this again it's to
identify the location of a drop and send
that to the to the decoder
um now we cannot solve the optimization
problem over the cell sizes for the for
the you quantizer in uh in close form so
we just write it as this optimization
problem over this these are the cell
sizes basically you know it's under one
they're non-negative this is their
entropy this is the Distortion they give
you
um so I guess this is not computable in
its current form or it's not evidently
computable but
um using LaGrange Duality you can get a
comparable lower bound
um it's quite good
so
to report this we also train the neural
networks on on the ramp instead of the
saw bridge and this is what we get so
this is a bit fine I don't know how well
this you can see from where you are but
so there's the the black curve the the
black solid curve the black dotted curve
so the black dotted curve is our lower
bound from from here
uh the black solid curve is the upper
bound we get by just choosing pis that
we like in this problem okay so the
optimum performance is between those two
curves they don't match but you know
good luck trying to thread a needle
you know through there especially up in
here they don't match but you know
they're almost on top of another and
then you train the neural network with
different values of Lambda that's
LaGrange multiplier that trades off the
Distortion versus the rate and this is
what you get so it's fine at low SNR and
then High SNR it peels off so
sub-optimal at high SNR although it's
it's on the curve at low SNR
so what's going on
so I have an explanation it's a bit of
an oversimplification okay but it's
better than nothing so
um
where I poke holes in part of the talk
like this would be the person to talk to
focusing because this is this is not
quite accurate but um it gets the basic
idea across so let's think about the
whole process end to end like imagine
you know nature picks the the phase you
and then you generate the ramp
realization that goes to the encoder and
then you can press goes to the decoder
and you get something out
okay so what we'd like to have happen is
for the encoder to extract the U like
the phase of the things that can be
describe the process and it's like 1D
it's simple it's uniform right
and then you quantize that and then the
decoder would get a quantize u and then
reconstruct this thing as best it can
from imperfect knowledge of view
and in fact the encoder you know seems
like the encoder had the harder problem
or it's got to like extract this 1D
variable from this thing and the decoder
have an easier job in fact it's the
opposite the encoder extracts you no
problem when we train it the problem is
that the decoder
so to see this think about the mapping
from you to like the process evaluated
at one coordinate you actually think
about it over here right so just like
you know evaluate the process at one
particular time and now it's very you
and think about how the process varies
at one particular time
so it looks like this
that's this this map right is you very
you this is how the process looks at one
particular time slice okay so it's
decreasing in you until it jumps up by
one and then increases again so that's
kind of the map you want to have from
here to here
um and when we train it however we get
is this
so the key difference being that we've
got
like these points here so it's like it's
not steep enough on the way up it kind
of catches some of the intermediate
values on the way up
um
you know at a very high level it's like
you want this the decoder to implement
this discontinuous function and like
it's a continuous function this in fact
it's differentiable so like it's it's
kind of limited in terms of how steep it
can be here
and that's the problem
so this explains why this only crops up
at low SNR
at higher scenario excuse me Lewis and
Art's fine highest scenar we have a
problem okay and the reason is like this
is always this phenomenon is always
present but at low SNR the Distortion
you pick up from this is sort of buried
by the noise that you get from just
quantizing you coarsely but a higher
scenario you're quantizing you very
finely and so the little bit of like
indeterminacy you have here dominates
your Distortion Like if the decoder gets
um
uh okay I can't guess I can't describe
what it was obviously in terms of this
plot but anyway
um the there's some indeterminacy here
in that like you know you're picking up
these values on the way up
um and that's that's dominating your
Distortion so we tried various ways of
fixing this
um we finally found one after quite a
bit of experimentation so to apply these
random Fourier features so there's this
paper tan stick it all to uh 2020. uh
which Builds on some earlier ideas from
rahimi and wrecked so the premise of
this uh tantric at all paper is that
um
stochastically trained neural networks
are hypothesized to learn high frequency
functions slowly
and low frequency functions quickly
they learn everything eventually okay
where they kind of learn the low
frequency functions first in the high
frequency functions like if you're doing
a simple regression or something right
it's like you know a function of one
variable they kind of learn the low
frequency functions a lot faster than
the high frequency ones and this is on
some level explains how they can avoid
overfitting because you can run them and
then you have this long window of the
train period where they've kind of
fitted the low frequency functions not
the high frequency functions yet and so
if you just stop it anywhere in that
window then you're good
sometimes you need to learn a high
frequency function like in our case
there's no way around it
so in that case tansik at all suggests
supplying the network with random
Fourier features that give it high
frequency functions of your data that
you have created so that it can easily
just pull them out you know and use them
so it would look like in our setup is we
modify the decoder if you do the encoder
too it doesn't really help but I
wouldn't hurt anything but anyway the
decoder is where you really need it so
rather than giving the the network you
or you had the quantized version you
would take the input U and then pass it
through all the sinusoids with like
random frequencies
okay and now this MLP has access to like
high frequency functions of U and so it
can you know just using Straight Like
free analysis you can kind of construct
this like steep
um Step function that it needs more more
readily than it has to do with
completely on its own
it's a bit sense of the hyper parameters
in case we'll start up some quite a bit
of time like optimizing these things to
get it to work but it does help
um in that when you induce demand for
your features then you're almost back on
the
on the Curve
right so
um yeah the classical story you know it
had a good run
um but uh perhaps I've limited utility
moving forward I say this is someone
okay who has spent a substantial portion
of his life working on IID quadratic
gaussian Source coding problems okay so
I I think I have standing to say it's
time to move on so
um so what does the future look like you
know I don't know
um but here you know two simple examples
to maybe start with the sawbridge and
the ramp simple as they are okay they do
meet these three goals they explain
success of these non-linear transforms
they quantify the Gap to optimality and
they do Point their way toward uh how to
improve them
um we have other processes we've looked
at they're not talking about so sign and
start with a random phase you know a
circle
it's a circle in 2D
so that's a low dimensional manifold in
a high dimensional space right it's a 1D
set in two Dimensions right so we looked
at that one too
um neural networks actually have trouble
compressing that one optimally similar
surprisingly given how simple it is
um Etc
and various extensions here let me just
mention two of them I think Network
extensions are interesting there are
groups looking at applying neural
networks to multi-terminal Source coding
to multiple descriptions
um we have gaussian results for these
they can compare against but I think you
know some kind of loading manifold but
maybe make more sense moving forward and
then you know
it'd be nice to generate some kind of
more demo Theory we've we've solved
various examples they're all one-off
theorems okay there's no like General
framework for these things as of yet so
it would be nice to
um to start work on that and I will end
there thank you
[Applause]
yeah
yeah so I'm very much doing deep
learning for a living so but I'm still
going to take this so my first claim is
these are really pathological examples
uh because
it's very very high because it's it's an
infinite dimensional
system if you take Fourier transforms or
any transform right so in that sense if
you restricted it's not going to do as
well and I I felt in some cases you were
giving side information to your neural
network
in both cases uh so and I'm not saying
you don't need non-linear transfers you
just so if you go back to read it's
called a bank and some other people's
papers can't remember who's where they
claim that cnns can be very well
explained by transforms plus simple
non-linearity
right linear transform Central the
simple non-linearity most images and
not entirely like this
it's a lot of smoothness there's some
edges
okay so there's a lot there my point is
um you took some external examples is
all I was saying yeah
okay I heard um let me try to tease out
the questions that I heard there are the
comments I heard so when was I I think I
understood you to say that you thought
um this fault with the neural networks
that we identified is not
um relevant in practice because it's
sort of a degenerate example and maybe
it doesn't doesn't wouldn't generalize
Beyond this no this was great not this
but the previous one the storage one
yeah okay
yeah yeah I mean this is great but it
didn't it feel like the neural network
is given sufficient prior information
about this kind of data set
um no and we just we just took
johannes's code and just ran it on Cyber
utilizations and then that was that just
did that
I thought you were saying the other
example with the random for your
features like you know we're kind of
hanging exactly starbridge yeah this was
totally off the shelf I could say they
have a completely clear conscience we
just ran it in the first time it just
just worked yeah so I don't think here
we were really providing it with side
information per se
in this example all those instances
yeah it learns to extract the
um the you exactly so if you give it
just one latent
Dimension that latent Dimension will be
basically you or some invertible
function of it if you give it two
um it'll usually turn off
one of them
so I just won't use it because it
doesn't need to
um although it will in some cases
um use it so if the rate Point
um that you're looking at is like log m
where m is not Prime and it'll like
actually use both dimensions uh you know
and use one Sue like indicate whether U
is like to the left or the right and
then the other one indicate like a
quarter so it'll you know it'll come up
with some clever schemes to use both but
it doesn't need to so you know we have
sometimes you train it'll just use one
and or the others
um in other cases it will some come up
with an optimal scheme that actually
splits into two kind of independent
latent variables
so the second example basically shows
there's a spectral element unit of these
systems which is why you want
those
yeah it's just not learning it needs to
learn to laugh basically and it was
learning the right and so yeah I mean
this I I agree with the criticism that
the skill is a bit too handcrafted you
know
um unless maybe you want to post just
always do this you know
um but it does it does fix the problem
and it's the only fix we really know of
as of now
can you back to your current where you
show you know your yeah this one or the
other process this one is good so what's
happening that you know the why is the
blue curve below the lower the yeah so
um
this is a
disagreement I've had with my co-authors
on this so the the blue is not a curve
okay so the blue is just the trained
neural network at different values of
the LaGrange multiplier so the blue is
really this this this this this this
this this this this and there's a dotted
line connecting them for visual purposes
but it's not to imply that you can
achieve anything here you can achieve
that and you can achieve that and that's
the assertion yeah so you have Converses
so true I'm sorry yeah
so um okay you know it's large scale is
one thing uh also maybe it's important
to point out that the entropy Distortion
curve is not necessarily convex
because you can't time share
if if the encoder is deterministic
anyway you know with a rate Distortion
problem you can always say like okay
I'll use like three quarters of my block
bank I'll do this and one quarterback
I'll use that and then you can
interpolate between any two points we
would formulate it is a One-Shot entropy
Distortion problem you can't time share
and so in fact neither of these curves
even just plot it not in a log scale but
just a linear you know linear scale it's
not a convex
um curve in fact I might even have like
at the end from a here
this is just mean squared error versus
entropy for the sawbridge so you can see
it
my condex
okay I think that's
sort of shaped that's well known you
know you know compression yeah I didn't
mean to imply this was like a new a new
observation but
um
you can't connect the dots
yeah just really uh maybe I misheard you
at one point I think before Durant you
mentioned or like as we were getting
into that that like the fact that the
function space is a circle here Place
several I was wondering maybe I'd like
missed a punchline here but it would
just like say a couple sentences about
like is there something about the
non-euclidean nature of that function
space that is screwing things up is
there a connection there or yeah
um
let's see
um maybe
um yes maybe you should describe in
terms of the circle it's like suppose
The Source was just like a point on the
unit circle in in 2D right so what you
want is for the encoder to just look at
the point in the circle and just encode
like the phase and the decoder and
quantize it in a decoder would then
reproduce you know point on the circle
or maybe below the circle because it's
like an mmse thing right
um but you think about the encoder's job
so it needs to
um read in a point on a circle and
output the phase right now the encoder
transform needs to be a continuous
function you want to be invertible
but you cannot map like there's no map
from R2 to r that Maps the circle
to the segment in a continuous and
invertible way right you can start with
a point okay map you know you map 12
o'clock to zero right and then you know
as you're going around you know you're
right you get to one and now what you
gotta quickly back come back to zero
right so
um so that's
um that phenomenon actually crops up
also kind of with the ramp it's another
way of thinking about what's going on
what's going on over here
um whereas this the strawberries not
have that property it's not returning
back to itself and so um you don't have
that same phenomenon wrapping up
okay thank you great thank you
[Applause]
oh great we're back at 3 25.
foreign